as a Viet the only thing I dealt with in
the South was my name is a dung and it
means poop in English but I use that uh
to make friends by taking it juggling
with them and not be serious and mad and
that's a really good way to do it and by
the way
whether you grew up in the South or not
people were still going to call you
dookie dude it don't matter where all
right even if you were in Sacramento
which was like all the Asians were
predominantly Chinese or Vietnamese we
still would have called you dookie a
hundred percent hey what's up dookie
wake up in the morning smell like a p
Duty huh
that [__] wouldn't have changed at all
you would have just had your own people
clowning on you that's it so I'm glad
that you took the route
of making it
into a positive thing because a lot of
people are gonna roast you either way
roasting culture is a big sign of
affection if you guys knows and I've
talked about this before where you know
growing up with just a very diverse
group of fans
um Everybody roasts everybody
specifically Mexican people man like
like the Mexican homies were so funny
like the parents would roast the kids 24
7. and you guys know this if I got
anybody who's Mexican here you guys know
that you have a [__] up nickname that
you never asked for and that's what
Mexican people do so [__] well hey
[__] Gordo Gordo just means fat it's
like bro like I I got a name but right
there my brother's nickname is Gordo you
know exactly what I'm talking about
hey good morning [__] hoto hey what's
up hey Dad chill with that
you'll be going to family parties just
dreading it if I ever came back as
another ethnicity like being Mexican
would be rough because I just know the
family parties I'm gonna get tossed the
[__] up
just gonna walk in [__] look at this
will be Mexican but his eyes are small
as [__] stop blinking and [__] open your
eyes like if you're not getting roasted
within the group and when everybody else
is getting made fun of nobody really
likes you then like you gotta understand
that like if you're within a group and
everybody's getting made fun of and
you're the person being left out where
they don't want to make fun of you they
know that you're [__] sensitive and
they don't want to put you a part of the
group uh you could be doing something
good and they'll still [__] make fun
of you it doesn't matter right you'll
you'll you'll come through and be like
hey guys I got a brand new car yeah
cause you're a [__] [__] right I
don't
how does that make sense but then you
have that one person in the corner that
doesn't like to be teased so everybody's
having fun except for that one person
and I hate those people if you can dish
it out then you should be able to take
it because usually that person who
doesn't want to be made fun of they love
making fun of everybody else but they'll
never take any they'll never take any of
the insults it's not fair that's not how
it works if you dish it out you gotta
[__] take it